music played the intro and outro music
for all the comedians who were coming on
stage it was a series of Comedians and
and a couple times I remember the
comedians themselves heckled me for
introducing them with lackluster music
everybody Hurts it wasn't that bad it
wasn't that bad about Snapchat but it
was um I remember like I was really into
TV jingles and um I still am and I
thought that'd be fun like who doesn't
like uh The Golden Girls for example you
take the good you take the best you take
them both and then you have Facts of
Life that'd be upbeat to me it was but
you you have like Melancholy taste in
music I do but and like The Shins you
know oh yeah so it's safe to say that's
not your calling at all you know what is
your calling otherwise hosting a podcast
oh I hope well let's see life could be a
dream life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short I am
your host podcast not dj Justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
and with me as always is my co-host and
brother Christian I'm trying to think of
The Golden Girls theme now you should
know this but friend
um your friend
oh uh friends uh this is good to see
what has happened in my defense I flew
from Vancouver last night and I I only
slept a couple hours [ __ ]
your friend there's so many people
listening
thank you for being a friend yes oh God
doesn't that feel good oh God I feel 10
pounds lighter it's also just such a
good song but I think I did play one on
with that song
um thank you for being a friend and it's
not comedians need like the energy of a
comedy club you need something that's
like it just raucous and really upbeat
like you know what always worked well
was um The Kiss song Groove uh New
York's New York Groove oh yeah you know
that was over I'm back in New York
anyway the point is I sucked at it and
um guess who doesn't suck at it well yes
you're right which is maybe the biggest
understatement yeah I know about this
person I know it's like saying uh
Michael Jordan doesn't isn't terrible at
basketball yeah do you know who doesn't
drown a lot Michael Phelps yeah yeah
that's funny
um yeah yes our guests today are
esteemed guest he does so much actually
um he is in addition to being the
probably biggest DJ I mean biggest one I
I think the most I think probably the
best DJ in the world the an iconic DJ
yes
um and he's also he's a he's a
documentarian he produces
sorry sorry and um he's a author he's a
philanthropist he's the band leader for
uh Jimmy Fallon The Tonight Show Jimmy
Fallon he wears a lot of hats a lot of
hats um he is Quest love oh yes I get to
call him a mirror which is pretty cool
his given name Thompson is his last name
but yes he's known to the world as Quest
love and um he is uh he's yeah the roots
he's one of the founding members The
Roots uh a a a another iconic he's got
he's like a multi icon and he has a new
movie a new documentary that he produced
that's out
um on Netflix descendant descendant yeah
it's an incredible story uh we get into
that Quest is one of those guess a quest
guest he's one of those guest love he's
one of those guests who it just does
there's too much there's too much to
talk about and he is a really good
Storyteller and just such an interesting
person
let's get right into it enough of us
let's get right into it now I gotta stop
saying that here it is our guest love
the iconic the multi-faceted Jack of all
trades Jack of all yes certainly
Questlove
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again
[Music]
and what do you prefer Quest oh we're
palsy yes nice most love was invented uh
so that I don't Twitch in the airport
when someone says I have a lot of hard
consonants in my name
that's true it's usually five in the
morning to seven a.m because I insist on
uh
the first you know I'm one of those
people that has to be on the first
flight out or whatever so yeah either on
the the red eye or the first thing out
and there's always that one guy that
just has to yeah go ahead
well on the one hand they're saying it
excite they're excited so that's
flattering
but it's yeah there it's a tough name to
to be hit with yeah but yeah but I do it
with the reaction of like you know like
whatever like a physical comedy actor
would have a drink in hand and oh yeah
it's a big almost like a John Ritter
request this is when I wish this were a
visual thing too because Quest just did
an uncharacteristically Big Move I've
never seen them here's the thing I
almost said Michael Richards oh I was
gonna say Michael Richard but here's the
here's the thing I live my life in terms
of Pop Culture references now that I'm
sort of on the market the dating Market
I've realized that I'm now I'm I'm hyper
aware of uh any pop culture references I
give because even now I'm in an age
where it's like yes Wu-Tang Clan I never
heard of them yeah what is that a
Chinese restaurant right exactly and so
I wanted to say John Ritter but
instantly I'm so shell-shocked from I've
prevented myself from giving any
reference that doesn't come before 2005.
so yeah and well then maybe it's also
the people that you're having to
reference things in front of hey man hey
I don't want to judge them
it's not their fault
but you also I'm surprised because you
also are so I I almost said um this in a
really nerdy way your hip in a tech way
you're Savvy you're tech savvy and I and
your power culture I would like to think
so but this is from my my perspective
because you always seem to know yeah
you're like an expert on things don't
you actually you talk about tech yeah I
mean I'm I'm ahead of the curve but yeah
I'll be honest with you usually November
December for me represents a whole
nother thing and this is where I start a
morning process because you know for
some reason I start the I start Rabbit
holding
about like what is the next year going
to bring I believe at the start of any
decade starts in the third year ah huh
so the zero the one in the two years
technically still the last decade right
so what will Define uh these new 20s yes
if we didn't have a preview already yeah
I know well hopefully I mean I hope your
theory is right I hope this is the sea
change so I feel like 2012 2022 was one
era and
so you know I just I start getting my
head about math and about um you know
just general things like I'm certain now
if I I'd spend Beyonce's Crazy In Love
uh which will have been 20 years old oh
my god well that reek of you know what I
mean so we could say like oh That's a
classic that's when the Nostalgia right
they start like right now Migos is about
to be old school Versace came out 10
years ago and basically in Hip-Hop
Hip-Hop and dog years are like the same
thing so yeah you've also talked so I
that's the things I think about
Halloween is when that starts because
even now I'm agreeing to do Heidi klum's
uh
oh the Halloween her Halloween party oh
the party you're gonna dress up then
like crazy dress-up I didn't even get to
that part like for me there's only
there's only two parties that matter in
a calendar year and that's Heidi klum's
Halloween party and Jay-Z and Beyonce's
gold party oh my God how different must
those be well it there's a lot of
pressure as a creative I put all the
weight and the pressure on those two
parties for how my creative DJ year is
going to go yeah I bet yeah there's got
to be a lot more pressure for the Jay-Z
Party it was I mean but I found I found
a niche formula
I know with that crowd just play poker
just play straight poker one of the most
disastrous DJ gigs I've ever had in my
life at the White House the last week of
the Obamas oh wow in front of in front
of who in front of the White House
correspondent oh no this was the last
week of the Obama oh oh so just think
about hanging out with them think of
like animal house like think of like the
wildest party I I haven't really gone on
record about how crazy that last week
was for the old farmers in the white
house but at one point I went in the
bathroom even the visiting bathroom is
almost like you know the Library of
Congress like it's oh yeah you know it's
like
couches and plush carpeting at one point
there was a a multi Academy Award
nominated actor
um
the light bulbs
get out of here oh we were all taking
everything
oh really you just Ransom I took I took
a spool of toilet paper
was it took a whole bunch of M M's
presidential Eminem's and I have a cup
is there something on them do they say
uh 44 oh yeah yeah the presidential M
M's are special colors it's like blue
white you know I went to the bathroom
and caught like literally I was like he
was like Mitch screwed and I was like
wait what are you doing and he was like
do you know who's coming in here like
it's going to be a [ __ ] show anyway so
you might as well take what you can get
he's gonna take a bunch of [ __ ] now we
know that he'll take a lot of stuff
right and I was like well you're right
so oh okay let me get a toilet paper so
I I at least have four minutes of of
Music still playing on the tour on the
thing upstairs and I was like big quick
and I saw the spool of toilet paper and
I was like
but I was impressed it was Cottonelle
and oh I was gonna ask I've never seen
Cottonelle individually wrapped uh
three-ply toilet paper what do you do
with that now where is it in your house
I am a hoarder I'm a pop culture
reporter yeah yeah which would make it
easier to date you'll have so many
references now dude all right so my ex
when she moved in I didn't realize that
I was living in my version of Pop
Culture collector's version of 40 year
old version
no no don't touch that it's in mint
condition right it literally when when
we kind of made the decision like all
right we're moving in together yeah yeah
she hadn't seen your stuff really no
she's seen it but she Shannon lived like
see the way that her eyes always like
darted towards like the corners of of
the apartment let me know that these are
the last times that I'm gonna see these
things
and it's only right because you know I
have over 200 000 records oh my God and
I'll say that half of those records at
least 90 000 of those records come from
uh she's making me like I have to sell
my record collection or even worse like
divorce settlement like out of spite I
got a real good 2
000 piece Jazz collection
from an out of spite uh because when I
saw what I was getting I was like wait a
minute like
these are mint condition and promotional
like these are special and she's like I
don't care like one of those
almost like I'll sell it everything to
you for 500 bucks and I'm looking like
yeah I just came from Japan and almost
had to pay 500 for this one album oh my
God oh my God and now that I've broken
up with said girlfriend like the house
is now getting Fuller and Fuller like
presidential toilet things I don't need
yeah exactly so my whole point was that
at that white house that particular gig
the surprise element that I wasn't used
to was that I forgot that I also have to
entertain people born after 1998. oh
yeah yeah and so there's one point where
like rule number one is you're never to
interrupt me when I'm DJing I don't take
requests like my opinion is like they're
very arrogant like I'm Picasso and you
don't tell me what to paint so there's a
point where on my shoulder
someone's tapping you and then my boy's
like uh you better turn around I was
like I was like sir so you go and he's
like hey uh you're doing great I love it
everything's great I love the Disco the
uh the Jazz the uh the the the the the
soul the the rock and roll the duo
you're playing everything I love it very
intelligent but uh any points over there
they want to have fun too
play something they know
and how about some cardi B dude
literally I'm witnessing a sit-in it's
literally like his two daughters all
their school friends their cousins
any celebrity that's like 23 20. they're
literally sitting down meanwhile like
the spielbergs Springsteen Jesse Jackson
Gladys Knight they're like having the
Rage of their lives
and it's hilarious and I'm like well I'm
playing Beyonce and then I'm realizing
oh even she's old to them yeah I mean oh
my God in 1998. I said sir
what do you call him you call him sir
he's now like call me Barry yeah yeah I
I didn't call him Barry back then yeah I
was like sir um call me sir
no he called me yes sir yeah
don't be Mr President
I said um I said not for nothing but um
like I have that music not for nothing
where I had to get Street you know yeah
yeah like on the real side on the grill
you blowing my eyes no no
I say look not for nothing but like I
have the music you're talking about but
I don't have the radio versions of these
songs and we're in the White House like
we're we're in this this place of of
high moral yeah
yeah it's not the factory underground
yeah and he was just like we're all
adults here go go go play it and man I
did the most ratchetist like
Atlanta strip club set of My Life coming
up next we have Destiny yo literally
this is what a stage so I was spinning
for two hours and at that point you know
I was like I had a good crowd at 1500
people wow maybe two thousand wow yo
when I started playing like ratchet trap
music
suddenly it was like the Smells Like
Teen Spirit video it was like it was
like 4 000 people oh really and I told
myself is still out there dude all right
so I looked at the side and my boy I'm
looking at my boy like yo where these
people come from and he's like I think
they was in the the other room waiting
for you to play something that they
liked oh my God and literally there was
one point of redemption for me and when
I say redemption
I mean more or less maybe I was evidence
sorting why I felt so guilty for playing
this music uh-huh it was the moment
where I catch Bruce Springsteen's eye no
man you remember that you remember the
commercial the indigenous native
american commercial where the guy cries
with one tier because solution yeah I
mean it's the height of everyone just
like matching oh no imagine Smells Like
Teen Spirit yeah I am on steroids and
there's a moment where Bruce Springsteen
who's hired me a few times to DJ some of
his After parties like whatever kind of
looking at me like I'm disappointed I
know you know better Amir
and literally he just grabs Patty and
gets out of Harm's Way because like
people
I'm not and I'm not Joe even like dog
even Stevie Wonder like like it was into
it it went from a dance party too almost
like a spiritual the culmination of
frustration that we were having at that
point especially about what was about to
happen in the next four years yeah
that's been happening the last three
years of this second Administration like
that release was coming and that's what
it was yeah it was like a sweat lodge
like spiritual like uh cacophony of like
like a shaman was throwing it or
something exactly Ayahuasca so end of
the night I just think it's the worst
[ __ ] I've ever done in my life
where I'm crying I'm about to have a
panic attack but you're making people
happy you're making the president not
just people so he's like uh end of the
night and for real it's almost like he
had everything but like his necktie
around his uh awesome that was amazing
my arms rolled up everything I bet yeah
it's like so uh you have fun you try the
food you try the food the waffles they
have breakfast like it was like three in
the morning so they made breakfast it's
like you gotta try the waffles best
waffles in the world and I was like nah
yeah that's cool and you know like is
that really how you're behaving are you
really like when you know you're about
to cry but like a real yeah
I know well the Heat's coming the chin
is quivering why beat boxing literally
yeah
so in my mind I was like all right he's
been through hell for these eight years
do not make this about you Amir
all you're gonna do
is however many blinks you gotta do to
put some tears back inside you're not
gonna have a dramatic moment
and just be like yeah you know oh I
didn't have any I'll do it later and
then he he instantly sees it he's like
hey are you okay
um no and I was like I'm fine man I'm
good I'm good no what's wrong oh no he
dug yeah and kept poking him yeah
and he's perceptive
he scratches the scab off and then I was
like I was like look man I said you
remember how like when you went to West
Virginia two weeks ago and you
specifically addressed all those coal
miners who got cancer and you're trying
to tell them look I want to give you
health care so that you can get yeah
cancer and they literally were like [ __ ]
in the face of help right yeah it was
very moving very difficult frustrating
right and I was like do you remember
that and they just rejected you and
you know and he's like okay he's I see
what's happening here he's like you're
you're an artist
and uh you calculated a moment you you
pre-planned and you you thought you knew
how the night was going to go
and uh but here's the thing and this is
the first time you know we all use pivot
in 2020 but this is
2016. and he's like but you pivoted and
you saw that uh maybe what you had
planned for the night wasn't uh going uh
as as you wanted
but what you did was great you you
adjusted and I I'm not I'm not blowing
smoke but you we had the time of our lot
oh man and what you did you showed the
people yeah you served yeah but by the
way is that a toilet paper in your
jacket
so it's almost like everything he said
you could hear like the the Fate you can
hear like Pomp and Circumstances in the
background
like that presidential marching band
music yeah like that moment where the
coach like ramps up the team in the
fourth quarter of the game to win yes
yes and it's like a natural at the end
of the natural I mean I know that's a
dated reference for you and uh you're
right exactly no no data references so
literally he um he's like he's real good
about yourself you feel good now and I
was like no I don't feel good and I left
here I
so I left and walking on the front House
lawn
and everything and I was playing Benny
Goodman and Lil Wayne they see the
genius in that like I was like
all those months wasted well lied to me
because I did the same exact thing at
the Hamilton after party oh really and I
swear to God I could have ran for
president like
so here's the thing I just took myself
out of commission I I stopped DJing for
six months off my face
and so when Jay and Beyonce talked me
into doing it I was in sort of Batman
Joker where did they get a load of me
like I had a name I was checking it
twice and
so I actually wound up doing the
Redemption like it went from whoa he's
good to you know he's really good too
like yeah oh my God how did you make
that happen and then it became like that
Marty McFly invented skateboard look at
him go thing like there was a more there
was a moment where like Diddy J Beyonce
yeah like Idris Elba like everyone just
stopped dancing yeah because clearly it
was like I I planned a sign like a
scientist reap like a vision of that's
an amazing Beyonce is like where she's
like I don't know but I'm gonna she's
like Lorraine Bates she's like I don't
know but I'm gonna find out where did he
come from right and so it was literally
it was it was it was such a Redemptive
moment to me that's awesome that when it
was time to do it the next year it was
like can you top it and I did yeah oh
boy and then last year after I won my
oscar it was like can he really top it
and the thing was with the last year I
felt that I had enough leeway to really
push the boundaries because they had
expectations they remembered like
remember that time you mixed belpit to
vote with Nirvana like oh my god really
they were like recounted yeah like
literally yo man I saw him DJ once and
when he turned to Stevie Wonder sample
the old dirty pass I was like oh my God
so to answer your question at the top of
the thing opened up the set playing
polka no I played having the uh
yes
into the song that Timberland sampled
for uh Jay-Z's Big Pimpin but they all
blend together and yeah like you know so
that was that was my whole thing so
right now how cool oh Jake entered to
impress Jay-Z like that
it wasn't your motivation but but that
that was the effect that it had how
[ __ ] cool I mean how if anything's
gonna make you feel better about the
presidential I I I want to say debacle
but in my mind I agree with I agree with
Barry I think I'm a big plate of fun but
to me it was like I gotta I gotta
remember that people will be more
engaged when you're not trying to preach
and teach them and to me I'm not doing a
DJ Gig I'm trying to teach the history
of music and trick you into dancing
you're playing for Jay-Z and Beyonce you
know and you're impressing these people
are you your own worst critic so it
doesn't really matter what people think
I also have to say that a lot of my life
transformation happened in the pandemic
so oh you know I'm telling you low
vibration Amir stories as opposed to
the work I had to do on myself during
the pandemic when you know when the
world stopped and we all had to deal
with ourselves but but you were playing
a lot of music during that time I
remember well that's I mean you were
still doing the zoom right that's it's
it's weird how it works out because
um I in in order to get out of my head
of the nervousness of making this
documentary which of course started with
hey we have all this footage and my
first thing was like well why don't you
get a real director then you know like I
was that person that yeah literally
tooks you never entertained it you had
never been like I mean you do so many
things
finally for them to tackle me and like
we're not taking them for an answer I
was just like let me just rubber stamp
it like get let me be executive producer
and I'll be you know Ronald McDonald
find a Ray Kroc to actually do the work
like
that's what I thought they're like we
don't understand that representative
[Music]
hey everyone not that you asked but I
just watched the movie nope I was really
Blown Away by the whole movie I loved
the movie I love Jordan Peele and one of
the Stars a bit Keke Palmer has a
hilarious new podcast baby this is Kiki
Palmer it's on Amazon music and You're
Gonna Wanna check it out Kiki has a lot
of burning questions that keep her up at
night for instance remember Tom from
Myspace remember that guy with a smile
in that little white T-shirt Tom what
happened to him Kiki Wonders that it
keeps her up and she attempts to answer
that she's putting friends family in
some of the hottest experts to ask them
the real questions we want to know like
how has dating changed in the digital
age where would former child stars be if
they weren't actors these are the
questions running through Kiki's mind
and she's letting us all in on it
because on baby this is Keke Palmer no
topic is off limits Prime members listen
to the Amazon music exclusive podcast
baby this is Kiki Palmer in the Amazon
music app download the app today it's
hard to imagine losing a loved one a
wife a husband a child for many it is
their biggest fear from wondering the
vanished is a podcast that covers the
stories of often overlooked and unsolved
missing persons cases every week host
Marissa Jones dives into a new case
sharing the details of their mysterious
disappearance from interviews with
family friends law enforcement and even
suspects in an effort to reveal the
truth the vanished has even aided in
getting long overdue arrests through
their in-depth interviews Marissa
reminds listeners of the human behind
the headline and aims to help family
members find their vanished loved one or
at least a sense of Peace follow the
vanished wherever you get your podcast
you can listen ad free on the Amazon
music or wondery app
also you do so much when it comes to
directing something like this it was so
ambitious and you get so many there's so
much footage just to call through I
imagine I don't understand how you have
the time for something like that here
fun fact fun fact back in my must-have
19 jobs
uh part of my life I'm at a normal six
now what are the what are the jobs now
it's obviously The Tonight Show uh I
still DJ I write books oh my God there's
uh my quest loves food uh venture
capitalist and my food Investment
Portfolio thing oh I direct movies I'm
forgetting like you steal toilet paper
yes
secondhand toilet paper Biz yes so no no
at one point it was 19. and uh oh my god
when I did my short stint for four five
years I taught at NYU
he's Jimmy's like he's Jimmy's warm-up
guy very funny guy friend of ours and
Zach says to me um this is like six
weeks before I'm about to teach my very
first class ah is it music theory what
he did yeah I'm teaching uh it's a music
course I I wanted to teach about um what
they call the departure album The
departure album is when when you make
your magnum opus when you make your
Thriller your rumors your Purple Rain
your sergeant well no actually Sergeant
Pepper is a departure record so the
departure album is artists can't help
but sabotage like remember when I told
you when good things happen to me the
first thing I do is say no I can't do it
I can't do it I think for a lot of
people and I always do this litmus test
with them especially when the Pixar's Up
was out I say to them if you're holding
5 000 helium balloons in your hand and
you slowly uh sort of escalate to this
guy how long is it going to be before
you're like no no I asked them in the
next five minutes if you're rising up a
centimeter per minute in the next five
minutes what are you going to do
I realize that people are more afraid of
the landing than they are of the
adventure of the unknown of the ascent
right huh like that's that would be the
most fun thing in the world right to
hang on to balloons and fly all over but
it's funny you're right that makes sense
that analogy is perfect people are more
afraid of how am I going to land am I
going to be safe
and that's the difference between brain
and heart people brain people want to
know well who's going to be there or
wait what do I got to do okay tell me
exactly what I'm doing
part people were just like Geronimo and
run and do it
yeah oh I I admire I envy those people
right and so Zog is like this is a big
step for you how are you going to
reprimand somebody if they're like on
their telephone and suddenly the strings
from psycho came in
and it hit me that this is the very
first job that I'm gonna take on that
doesn't leave me hiding in place because
I realize I made a career for myself
hiding in place oh that's interesting I
hide behind the turntables I hide behind
Jimmy I find Tariq drum set this is the
first time I'm gonna have to look people
in the eye and teach and I was scared
out of my mind so the fun fact about
Seth Herzog is
uh
he was like well the best way for you to
get rid of your fear of communicating
with people is I'm gonna have you just
start doing stand-ups and open mics so
that was his way of getting you to do
sweet he does that show that was very
clever very roundabout way okay no but I
went to other spots too really really
what was that like well he would he
would just play my wingman like Seth
lives in yes and constant totally yeah
there was there was one time where there
was a guest of the show an hour before
Showtime got canceled
oh my God no but canceled in a real way
where it was like a scandal and it was
just been not a good look to like this
person is like in the headlines number
one trending and he's also the guest on
The Tonight Show no what did they had he
already recorded So we we always have an
emergency rotation usually like there's
somebody from 30 Rock upstairs at SNL
like all right call arms call Fred down
or call Cecily yeah whatever you see
like an SNL guest on uh
it's probably someone who canceled or
whatever
and so but this is one of the rare times
where we kind of had to stall to find
somebody to fill in I think the person
we found was like a a sports person who
you know just happened to be there
wasn't Rachel Maddow I don't know funny
I remember getting a call similar to
this like hey can you quickly do the and
I was like yeah when you get that yeah
that's where you are on the list you're
way down to me you're coming to me right
it must be trouble
wow
and so
Zog usually the warm-up protocol is
he gives the uh the safety things like
there's the emergency exits no photos no
flash photography he does that small
talks for like three minutes then The
Roots come out we do a song
and then he does the where's everyone
from thing and if they're from far away
he jokes about Australia whatever yeah
it's tough job crowd work it is yeah and
after 15 minutes the show starts
without any context whatsoever
Zog and we can't explain to him what's
happening backstage because it's going
to require like oh yeah okay so I just
what happens
yeah right yeah right all that [ __ ] yeah
and so without any context whatsoever
Zog winds up having to do
a 90 minute warm-up no oh the Wonder
Woman costume we did four Stones oh my
God uh we celebrated birthdays I gave
away all my drumsticks oh the audience
must have loved it well after a while
then it was just like he had to go to
each individual person so where are you
from so what do you do what kind of
college is that and he's just running
out of punchlines oh my God and then it
just became hilarious to everyone we
didn't say what the specifics was but we
were just like all right Zach's like
I've I guess we lost a guess I was like
yes yeah he lost the guess but I do
remember that I believe after that
moment we decided to have different
levels of like uh Sizzle reel kind of
entertainment things like highlights of
the show
it's like an emergency Sizzle reel yeah
but but he can do it but he forced me to
enter the world of stand-up comedy for a
good three weeks wow that makes sense
too to not have that barrier uh your mom
came to the Oscars right yes uh how what
was that like to I mean what if
especially for somebody who you know
tends to undersell themselves and like
this is obviously the Pinnacle of that
world it was a slow journey and slow
Journey as in the road to the Oscars
also means that there's about 30 other
that's true events you go to right right
Director's Guild producers Guild you
know independent uh spirit Awards
Sundance Awards you know yeah you know
by that point and of course you know I
know everyone's curious about my
category and the incident that happened
with the slap but I didn't see that part
[Laughter]
you should have been there yeah well I
guess I'll never know I don't know if
you guys saw it at home but uh there's a
point where Amy Schumer came out like so
what did I miss yeah that's right that
was funny that was funny yeah oh okay
they did they did show that yeah
um but for me and again like artists are
always neurotic artists are always
evident sorting why they don't deserve
[ __ ] and just by that point I was
feeling like the Grinch that stole
Christmas
yeah especially the doc Branch we're so
closely connected to each other and
you're making friends and then as the
year goes by then you know things start
to whittle down and suddenly like it's
10 of you yeah we've all been together
uh for like almost a collective year it
starts with Sundance wow and it ends a
whole another year later right for the
Oscars so it must be feel weird then to
be like Oh I'm I get the thing over you
and like yeah and we're right and we're
all sitting together and the thing is
like I'm sitting next to Stanley Nelson
yeah who basically created the very
first documentary I've ever seen in my
life which was if you're if you're a
young black kid in the 70s in the 80s
your parents are going to make you watch
a documentary called eyes on the prize
oh it's the best look at the civil
rights movement in a documentary called
eyes on the prize and Stanley Nelson
does this and you're just sitting there
like yeah I'm sitting there with sailing
Nelson but then like you know flee took
so many years to make it like flea was
like a 13-year process to make because
it's animated and you're just sitting
there like dealing with the anxiety of
am I going to win what's going to happen
to my life and also like do I deserve
this and they work so hard too and I
don't want everyone yeah and there just
has to be a point and I had to learn
this after the Oscar like where I'm such
the people pleaser yeah that um I have
to get out that place where I'm I'm not
going to Joy or Revel in a moment I'm
the same way I feel you yeah so even
when that particular uh you know
slapplicious yeah I Gotta Give it cute
yeah right so when the slapping happened
um when it slappened yes when it's
slapping yeah
um I one I was uh I learned about micro
meditation
um weird enough through Seinfeld
um Seinfeld uh put me hip to a cat named
Bob Roth
so if ever for people that give like a
lot of speeches and in this case like
his nervousness of going out on stage to
a new crowd or whatever
so Jerry does he sits for five minutes
does Michael meditation and he's like
that's the secret to his success oh wow
every lunch hour every lunch hour of
Seinfeld he would micromeditate for his
45 minutes in his trailer what no
kidding micromedical and that's the
secret that gets him out of his own way
that gets him out of that neurotic I
don't deserve this up oh wow so Bob Ross
from so two minutes before that moment
I'm already like when Chris is there I'm
like oh this is my category what am I
going to do so I'm already like eyes
closed
and that's so ironic yeah right and I
heard I heard one expletive looked at my
mom like wait are they allowed to say
that on National Television
and I looked and I don't know what's
going on and I was like wait is that
real or is that a sketch uh yeah yeah I
bet I don't want to use that energy of
that because you're literally seconds
away from
your life so I went back to
if so and then I heard it and then yeah
as I'm walking to the the the podium
that's when there's a weird energy in
the room now that's when I realized like
oh wait what just happened yeah and so
when I get on stage half that perplexed
look was me trying to figure out in
record time
okay that wasn't a sketch well you have
to process all of that as you're about
to give yeah yeah and I gotta remember
like 17 names it's right don't forget my
mom don't forget to thank my girl for
like all these things so I I did a I
kind of did Seinfeld and was like when I
I just I was like three seconds
I was like just start talking and I
don't know what I said it'd be funny if
you were like what's the deal with
speeches and award show you know just
started sounding weirdly like
how many deserving nominees and I'm the
one who gets it
um right yeah I I it was it was really I
I mean I remember thinking oh [ __ ] good
for Quest that was back when I was
calling you and thinking of you as Quest
before you gave me perfect before I
insisted that yeah I mean by my
government name yeah so I was like wow
good for him I mean you just seem so um
measured and like appreciative it was a
great speech but I remember yeah I'm
sure you're sick of hearing this but
like I was bummed for you that that
moment your moment was um you know had
had to be like had that surrounding it
and it was probably super annoying to
then go backstage and now here we are
many months later uh talking about it so
I don't want to bore you with it but um
no no I mean you know I'm I'm gonna I'm
probably in the the fourth or third most
viral moment in television history
that's true that's wild maybe I'm
Charlie Brown I'm not the star of my own
Halloween special
um but you're uh who would you be Linus
maybe you know a Schroeder I I will say
that everything that happened from that
night on uh was a major life change
uh yeah but it it was an impact that
that was necessarily to shake me and
wake me up to where it is now oh yeah
and yes I went through every emotion
Under the Sun yeah I went through crying
episodes near manic episodes celebratory
episodes yeah I went through I literally
went through everything but I do think
that I came out wiser yeah isn't that
amazing for it but it was never but for
me it was really never if you're asking
me like what was the main issue of that
night in hindsight yes this the slap was
traumatizing and the slap was not I mean
it I'm underselling it if I say it's
unnecessary yeah yeah
um but I will say that for me I already
had a bigger elephant in the room and
that was the whole worthy of even being
there in the first place my ex actually
said to me like you're such a master
manifester that you actually
got what you wanted I was like what do
you mean
you love nothing more than hiding in
plain sight ah yeah huh wow interesting
yeah you wanted to win that award
in the most quietest
non-disruptive way like sort of an act
of God if there's a way for me to win
this award
in the quietest way possible to not
offend anyone or get anyone mad at me
please let it happen it's true and it
happened it happened it was in the wake
of that kind of a a moment that's yes
that's really funny and interesting
um uh too much to talk about but I but I
want to touch on uh clotilda the um yeah
this is I know it's such a big issue um
and and it's fascinating I went down a
rabbit hole myself
um about it I I can't believe they still
had slave ships back then that they're
still smuggling slaves in after it was
almost 50 it was 1807 was the they
prohibited the act of Congress
prohibited the slave trade and here in
1860 there's the that's the last they're
still doing it they're still doing it
how
um well well America is going to America
yes and so that's America be americaning
America is going to America and the rule
number one in America is you can't tell
me what to do so yeah you know
essentially what wound up happening was
um because of of this slavery uh ending
and now being punishable there's a
capital violence right yes by death yes
these two sharecroppers uh met a ship
captain and they had a bet and the BET
was I could still smuggle some slaves in
oh my God and does it on a very small
scale
um is that Timothy me here me here
Timothy mayor mayor yes mayor and so
what winds up happening is he goes to uh
the west coast to the uh I guess uh to
Liberia Nigeria Nigeria and they are in
a civil war with Benin which is another
part of the West part of Africa small
country and with those uh 110
um captives on on the uh on this on the
ship uh they come back to America of
course uh the British bust them all over
and it wasn't I mean it was more like
having cocaine in the car is illegal
like that's right right right you didn't
pay taxes for this free labor you know
that's right yeah it wasn't like
outraged that you were shipping human
beings exactly yeah and so what winds up
happening is you know they both snitch
on each other well he made a bet well he
bet us that didn't uh yeah those guys
weren't didn't have like convictions and
they weren't uh they got convicted yeah
and so meanwhile my so my great great
grandfather was literally the last one
chosen because wow the clotilde was such
a small ship that they figured you know
the best way to to pack and store
captives was just get the young ones so
grab all the grab the kids the the two
to 13 year olds pack them and give them
to America and you can get you know good
use out of them someone starts at 13 and
ends at 60. and so they were taking them
from their parents obviously yeah so a
lot of right so the trauma of being
kidnapped oh my God then he's like well
wait uh all right so give 30 back and
bring more women in and so that they can
be more maternal and loving to them and
oh my God then calm them down and then
so then they're crying and he's like
wait a minute is 110 of them and there's
only six of us and only got six guns uh
I need someone to control them and so my
greater great grandfather was six foot
five he was 50 years old and single
which is kind of weird yeah so I'm not
I'm not even in history yet
like he's single 50 years old and yeah
and so he's the last one chosen to sort
of be like the authority figure oh my
god
um to calm them down from crying wow and
um so when they finally land in Mobile
Alabama unsuccessfully you know he's
like all right so can we go home and
they're like uh yeah they they burnt the
[ __ ] together oh my God he's like well
can we have his land and they're like
well you can't have it but we'll sell it
to you and it just so happens that there
was a large population of Benin West
Africa same language same mother tongue
um Nigerians and Ghana people in Alabama
oh wow and so he basically said look
let's put all of our money together
we'll start Africa town we'll take this
2 000 square acre land and we'll build
our Huts like we'll act like we're in
Africa so since we can't go home we'll
bring home here and so essentially this
is a documentary that is about life in
Mobile Alabama in which the last African
captive started a community that's so
wild and sort of the after effects of it
because there's you know some generation
kids way younger than me that want to
sort of leave the town and start their
own lives and stuff you know but then
there's pressure on Surviving people to
remember every name and remember the
traditions and then there's also the
fact that you know uh the person that
owned the farm and the his land Atomic
mayor
like yeah there's still problems
yeah like they still have successful
businesses but also you know there's
like chemical factories surrounding
Africa town so there's pollution and
cancer death and all that stuff so
there's a lot of issues
um in there but essentially this is a
story of how a town sort of deals with
the trauma of what happened to it like
200 years ago so and and the effects of
which are still being felt obviously so
talking speaking of you know relevance
and why things why things need to be
remembered and that's I can't wait and
that's coming out um it's gonna be on
Netflix Netflix in October and yeah and
if you get and if you get nominated for
that you will probably most likely not
go to the Oscars
well I mean you know even though I'm
producing this uh with the higher ground
people which you know are my friends uh
Barry Michelle
uh I will never hesitate I will never
hesitate to to to do uh an Obama
impression yeah I know it's the they're
the best yeah yeah we're the producers
and um you know again I I think this is
another situation where I'm not entering
in a situation where it's like oh we
gotta win the Oscar yeah yeah for me
just just to find out who I was oh my
God I was five years ago like I didn't
know what Benin was it was on that show
it was on that discovering you're right
yeah so just so that that happened was
Elation then to find out like there's
more to the story oh it's an amazing
story yeah so you know I I got my reward
yeah I could uh well I can't wait to see
it life could be a dream sweetheart
quick lightning round if you will Amir
uh what is your favorite emoji your
go-to emoji the frustrated eyes closed
oh ah I always have a kind of a pie in
the face moment so you don't like the
hand in the face like that oh man no
okay um
that's my constant face that's my go-to
mode okay matter of fact I tell people
all the time like my new version of how
your day was I don't do that anymore
because I don't believe in people saying
yeah I'm fine yeah I tell them
I don't yeah but I tell when I first
meet people I tell them to screenshot
their most used emojis oh that's really
that tells me everything about a person
it's funny in mere seconds yeah yeah
um in a mere seconds
um unless it's like some random you have
to be right I'm thinking I I keep
sending strawberries to my to my
girlfriend and it would be way too
difficult to explain that um it's
hickies yeah you got it okay well I
guess it's not technical uh who was your
first celebrity crush I remember the
look of horror on my mom's face when I
told her that I love Betty Rubble
she had a really good on the back of my
on the back of my Fruity Pebbles yep I
get it um she had a really good eight by
ten headshot
hey look at least Betty Rubble was a
human being a cartoon character I I
liked uh made Marion from the Robin Hood
from the Disney Robin Hood
she was in the Box some Bistro but if
it's a but if it's a human being it's a
tie between Raquel Welch and Maria from
Sesame Street oh yeah very different wow
the real Spectrum
um who what is your what is your
favorite ice cream flavor
no more sugar for me okay my favorite
ice cream flavor I would say that my
default thing is I I love Oreo ice cream
oh yeah yep yep um cookies and cream
um what is your favorite holiday Amir
Halloween I think I've defined My Life
by Halloween I'll see that Halloween is
my favorite holiday and is there a um in
a clay movie maybe a horror movie that
in this time time of year a spooky movie
I'm not a horror guy um oh really I'm
I'm a thriller guy like what would you
consider Silence of the Lambs it's a
thriller right uh it's funny we we have
that on our list to watch for Halloween
it's it's a thriller I would say more
than a horror have you ever find them
all right I'm really gonna mess your
viewers up one time I I was yelling at
um Eli Roth you know he he would direct
these like horrible extreme like like
hostile and Cabin Fever yeah and
Tarantino's telling me like wait I'm not
violent like this guy is violent and
he's like at least you know with the ear
slicing scene I turned the camera away
but this guy will show the knife going
into someone's retina and both of them
told me he's like both of them tell me
you've seen nothing and experienced
nothing until you've watched this film
called the audition uh we have it on
we're we're watching it this week ever
seen the audition no it's on our list
the audition we it's a Japanese friend
is your girlfriend in love very much so
there's two movies I recommend you don't
watch with your partner oh really
number one is match point oh yeah yeah
number two is the audition really
because it just it messes with you
psychologically wow because it's really
not I can't wait a thriller or a horror
film but just that it goes so dark in
unexpected places that well yeah I just
did this movie Barbarian which is why I
saw you last on The Tonight Show and um
that the director of that who who now I
really trust he came up with his list of
top horror movies and audition was
number one I don't know if it was in any
particular order but he yeah it was
really inspiring Roth and Tarantino were
like we don't have [ __ ] on why oh [ __ ]
okay well now okay
um what about you uh I mean is there an
acclaimed movie that you haven't seen
that you're kind of embarrassed to admit
you haven't seen I know you've seen
because you're such a movie guy okay so
I'm the guy that lived on a tour bus
from 17 years like between 93 2008 2009
um and up until recently I finally
crossed off all the Star Wars I was
never a Star Wars guy well that
surprises me I know I'm I'm a I'm a geek
that has no pedigree I'm a geek that has
no pedigree of the films that are
necessary I still have not seen any of
the Lord of the Rings ah yes I just I
will say that I've seen the Godfathers
enough to just to say that yes I've seen
The Godfather yeah there's a long period
where huh I didn't even watch the
Godfathers like all the classics I
wouldn't watch but it was my job to
provide all the DVD entertainment on the
roots tour buses yeah and I'm like Art
House Criterion Collection yeah like
well Christmas once I actually got David
I think um for David and Amber David
Cross and Amber tamblin uh
um for their uh post wedding like I got
them every Criterion Collection DVD oh
that's a great gift I'm I was that
person I was like Art House film
Criterion Collection guy and then funny
they're like do we need to watch another
Todd salons movie quit on the bus we're
just trying to like relax
that's that's my that's my thing right
there yeah I would say that
um I should probably watch The Lord of
the Rings
um well series now there's a new one you
can watch
um uh what is what is your favorite
cereal come here peanut butter Captain
Crunch oh wow yeah greatness you like
the puffins if you want to be a little
healthier well actually you know I'm I'm
one of the First Investors in um magic
spoon oh okay yeah the magic spoon is a
low sugar cereal if if you're a person
that is taking sugar out of your diet
you know like when you used to go on a
town if you ever had to go on a diet but
like back in the day when die Coke used
to taste like nasty as hell
yeah you lower your sugar than settling
like hey this tastes like regular Coke
like that sort of thing uh it's I I
would say that it would take 14 days for
you to get used to for your mind to be
like this is not Cocoa Pebbles no I
won't eat this cardboard but yeah magic
spoon to me is the oh wow that's cool
you know oh all right I'll check that
out
um and do you drink uh coffee or tea and
if so how do you take it
um I like mocha mocha yup I'm not a
coffee guy
um but there was a point where I would
take two triple espressos before every
Fallon so did I just basically meant to
your listeners that I I do bumps before
yeah basically yeah
right
ladies and gentlemen
yeah I I um there was a point where for
a good six year stretch I was is taking
two triple espresso shots but Amir in
your defense that that whole atmosphere
has that I I when I just finished doing
it I came back to the hotel and I my
girlfriend was like yeah this
everything's okay I was on this like
I was so amped up I mean there's this
the energy there is like even when Jimmy
comes backstage and like I I've had I've
known Jimmy for years and he's like
what's up buddy hey Matt oh and we're
doing bits and like it's big you know
it's um a lot I've you know for me like
normally because it's so cold there that
should keep me up but there will be
sometimes there's one particular guest
that you you remember you remember the
sloth and um I forget the name of that I
don't know yes zootopia yeah there's
there's there's a guest that sort of has
the motor skills of that Salon
I can't wait to I got this script uh oh
boy and then like he's that slow yeah
um and I remember there was one or there
was once where Jimmy
grin like caught me mid yawn
so it was like yes tomorrow like I'm
smiling like attack
and I didn't want that to happen again
so I was like all right I need all the
caffeine in the world so I started
drinking oh that's funny shots of
espresso before the show
um if you uh amir's a great name but if
you had to choose a different first name
where did Questlove come from I mean I
guess you have children I hate monikers
I hate
um
when like anytime someone names
themselves in hip-hop it's always a
dated name yeah that will clearly tell
you which era they came from like you
know where the Fresh Prince came from
yes you know where Lil Wayne came from
like yeah see the right and so I I had a
really unsuccessful run at giving myself
a name and so when we got our record
deal like at first it was it was
horrible my first name was defto money
def I'm guessing def dope
no no no I'm not going there and we want
to keep our jobs
no money and then Tariq gave me some
weird like Divine technician on the drum
set yeah or something like that and then
I was eight then I was a sample and then
my fourth time around I was just like
look man I'm gonna be nothing I'm just
gonna be uh
I'm gonna be a question mark yeah the
artist formerly known as right and this
was like a year before Prince changed
his name so I was just like when people
ask me I'm gonna struggle my shoulders
like yeah oh God would that be a great
that'd be actually kind of like a baller
and then you'd have to be introduced
like ladies and gentlemen right and then
you just start playing so what winds up
happening is that that is exactly what I
do for the first record and everyone's
like so mark would you I was like wait
why y'all keep calling me mark question
mark your question mark right your
name's Mark damn it so then our second
album I overdid it and did like the
world's most pretentious moniker acronym
ever so I decided I'm gonna be brother
question and that was beat recycler of
the Rhythm brother question but then
every journalist was like brother yeah I
was like why do y'all keep saying that
well it's like brother with the
exclamation point you thought it was
brother
that's funny third time around I was
just like look I'm gonna go old school
and when you're old school it's it's
three names you're either gonna be Rock
ski or love and only recently LL Cool J
revealed to me he's like well I'm glad
you're not ski because you don't seem
like that type of cat you know I mean
and I was like wait that's what that
means he's like yeah man ski means snow
okay so skeelo does well he was
s-k-e-e-s-k-i it was cool rock ski from
The Fat Boys Joe ski love from Bismarck
no not Bismarck Bismarck ski
[Laughter]
uh oh yeah so
um Quest didn't roll off the tongue
neither did Quest Rock
um so then West love was like that that
was a cool last name there was a kid in
my class uh his name was William love
and all the girls loved him like yeah
yeah I'm William love and I was like all
right that's my name now I like it it's
smooth and love and why not say look
it's a good word to say it's a good word
to put out in the world
um if you had a sandwich named after you
come here the quest love uh at a fancy
Deli let's say what would be on it I'm a
Philadelphia in so I it has to be well I
have my own sandwich if you if you call
the gold I feel like those 19 jobs I'm
talking about now is now
you're a sandwich artist well here's my
cereal and now here's my sandwich no if
you go on gold belly yeah oh I love go
Billy yeah well there's
um I'm one of the First Investors in
impossible company and
I wanted to make a Cheesesteak wow yeah
that philadelphians that can eat but
plant-based people wanted to cool have
fun too so that is technically the quest
loves Cheesesteak but I will say that um
whatever it is it has to contain an
Amoroso
Amoroso role is a Philadelphian religion
okay it's not a sandwich unless it has
an Amoroso roll and I don't want to
create any contention among up
philadelphians but what is your go-to
when you go back to Philly what's your
spot what's the cheese stick
um you know I will say that um
Dalessandro's is probably the one that I
would recommend to people
um but there there's a guy uh in
Philadelphia named J.L Jupiter who
literally is like the Bourdain of
Philadelphia uh in terms of like giving
you the hole in the wall spot that is
three Michelin star worthy cool yeah
jail Jupiter and um he just you know he
puts out his annual I'm waiting for I'm
waiting in addition to waiting for each
con which is the Coachella food yeah
this weekend
um I'm waiting for jail Jupiter's uh top
five Cheesesteak list oh nice okay I'll
check that out yeah um and do you prefer
the uh favorite Tom Hanks movie a movie
if you could only watch one Tom Hanks
movie again what would you hold on to
they're gonna take away all the other
ones ah it's so easy to say big isn't it
yeah but then you watch it it's like oh
it's it's great on so many levels it's
so weird because as a kid growing into
puberty yeah that bachelor party poster
was everything oh it's the best yeah
yeah with the pro yes I know exactly I
don't want to go into why but I know
exactly yeah
um but I
um I know I'm gonna miss something like
my heart's with big
but I know there has to be yeah I'll say
big good uh it's uh yeah it's better not
overthink the uh the town it's like it's
it's there for a reason it was at the
tip of your time for a reason yeah
um a toilet roll over or under do you
have a preference man I'm gonna tell you
something
um signs of a true Bachelor I'm so lazy
now now that I'm back in this house
alone
I'm the guy who will let the toilet
paper go down to the its very last thing
and instead of just taking it off
replacing it with a new one I will take
the new role and balance it on top of
yes
yes yes
yep that's a bachelor move
um and and lastly Amir finish the
sentence if you will life is short so
walk it [ __ ] it oh wait that could be
taken two ways
no okay anyway I mean I mean in that
Risky Business yeah sort of like jump in
the pool like I don't mean literally as
in a verb like yeah no no not make love
to it yeah yeah I just mean life is
short so yeah what the hell yeah I like
it Amir this is the best thanks and tell
Zog and Jimmy and everyone I say yeah
thanks man this was two two good it's
all right hard to stop thanks Amir all
right
[Music]
so that just happened
uh how would you uh he's got a little
bit of a yo to laugh I love his laughs
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's a great lab
yeah he's um it's fun to make somebody
like that laugh too because he has such
a it's jovial there's something really
like um and and full-bodied he's got a
full-bodied laugh and a very rich brain
oh man does he um how fertile is that
brain the reference you want a brain yes
it's a hell of a brain pick yeah oh my
God he um yeah I it's funny that he's
the he's concerned with his dated
references
in like dating life now
um because he's so funny references
because he's so full of I mean he knows
so much like he's like a pop culture
wizard so it must be so challenging I
kept imagining him on a date with
someone who's a bit younger and I
imagine it being so challenging for him
not to make not to be able to make
certain references because they're so
like on the tip of his brain but then
doesn't that mean you should date older
people yes that's what I thought but
yeah who I mean I'm not telling him I'm
just saying I'm just saying naturally if
that is that's kind of how he the world
he lives in yeah you know the the the
references that he trafficks in
um wouldn't that mean it'd be easier
just easier to relate I've dated people
of different ages my life and I always
find it so nice and helpful when the
person you're dating is around your age
he's getting the reference where they
get what you're talking about and vice
versa well but then the flip side is I
I'm just just to play Devil's Advocate
again to my own point you learn new
stuff you learn new stuff I know yeah
and also so what it's like okay so
somebody doesn't know the NeverEnding
Story uh see I think it's an it's a
really nice bonding thing to have the
same cultural touchstones you know I met
um one of the guys I'm working with he
has an incredible story he's from Tibet
such a different he was telling me a
little bit about what it was like living
there and I was so interested in him but
I felt like it was so difficult to
relate him it'd be so difficult to you
know spend significant time with
somebody like that like a sherpa is that
one of the reasons you've you haven't
climbed a very impressive Mountain yet
because you're afraid of the
conversation with the sherpa yeah but
the social time I'd be spending it's a
good excuse not to do it you know this
extremely physically demanding thing I
would do it I would climb Mount Everest
but what would I talk to the sherpa
about yeah I feel like we'd run out of
conversation at like the closet feet oh
yeah The Climb would be a piece of cake
I could do that in my sleep yeah but
what the hell would I talk to Sherpa
about yeah we would just be climbing in
silence it'd be awkward that'd be weird
um I met a sherpa once he was uh he was
an Uber driver and if I had a nickel for
every time I've heard a story starting
that way it's funny that but I was like
I kept making jokes about how we were
every time we go over like a little Hill
I'd be like oh I'm so glad you're with
me you're everybody loved that well well
he was really playful and funny he he
had never climbed a mountain what yeah
not all Sherpas he was from Sherpa it
was his name too and they're part of the
tribe there I think in um Tibet Nepalese
tribe
um but and and you know he comes from
obviously a long line all of his
relatives are were able to climb
mountains but he just laughed at a
certain age and so he probably has in
very impressive lung capacity that's
what I said I said do you find yourself
when you climb stairs and stuff and he's
like well I have nothing to relate it to
but I I guess I'm pretty you know he's
like I'm gonna I can climb stairs and
stuff oh my God we're just at our
nephew's birthday party and all the kids
were running around and they came back
and I noticed that none of them were out
of breath isn't that funny and then I at
one point I I jogged around the
perimeter of the yard for like a minute
and I came back and I was like gasping
for air so sad I I told you the first
day of dodgeball practice that we had
when we were doing the movie
um I just went so I went like gung-ho I
was also trying to impress everybody I
was so like eager to have that job out
and the next day I um I literally
couldn't move quite a bit I couldn't
stand up and you were a younger man then
yes I was 25 I went back to the last
time I had played Dodge but was I don't
know 15 years earlier in school 10 years
earlier and when your body's just you
know just
you know this conversation so far is I
think very appropriate for the episode
we're doing because your conversation
with Questlove was a bit it was really
interesting but it was all kind of all
over the place it was it was very like
rabbit holy yeah and I feel like that's
what this outro is so far well that's a
good rabbit hole it's why I like hanging
out with you and it's why I like hanging
out with Quest I like kind of traveling
around I like chasing each other yeah
and not completing stories yes yeah uh
it's cool that he let you call him a
mirror it is cool you're like oh great I
know I really felt uh that Obama story
is great but I didn't totally understand
it because I thought the ending was
Obama comes up to him and he was like he
put his arm around him he thought it was
going to be like pivoted and you and you
ended up impressing the kids and we had
the craziest party Obama's ties around
his head and he described like the most
the most successful party yes and he
pulled it off yeah and then he didn't do
it for six months because he was so
dejected and he was crying as he left
the White House I don't get it well I
guess the lesson is that it's all your
your own worst critic and and you have
to really battle yourself you have to be
okay you have to get good with yourself
but he succeeded he objected I know but
he's not with himself he never got okay
with he never became okay with the idea
of letting himself down so he so he he
knew he didn't let the president down he
didn't let the party goers down did you
let Bruce Springsteen down I don't think
he let anyone down except maybe Bruce
Springsteen maybe oh maybe that one
maybe that's but I think it's more about
himself letting himself down because he
had this whole I think he has like a
real um he's a really like genius music
oh my God you think no no but I Know
Have You Ever Seen The Tonight Show no
he is but in a way that I think like
emotes are you are your own you hold
yourself to your own high standard I
guess I don't know what it's like to be
a genius I I can't I can only I can only
certainly not a DJ genius no no
everybody knows uh yeah I forgot the
girl the Golden Girls song again I was
just about to sing it thank you for
being a friend I see I bet he would um
I I don't know what it's almost like a
mathematical brain he has it's oh he
would blend that song in with like who
let the dogs out he probably connects
things that are like how does a human
brain think to do that he's a musical
magician and just to do that I mean like
look no further than like how quickly he
needs to play certain songs that that
happens a lot on The Tonight Show where
he's like Jimmy will reference something
like uh it's kind of like Back to the
Future and Marty McFly and they're like
that's the power and they start playing
yeah you know
they'll go right into it that's amazing
should we read a letter oh yes I'm just
seeing a big yellow heart which I love
on the on the letter but that's not all
the letter is That'd Be Wild
um it's from Carrie mckierland
m-c-e-r-l-e-a-n LG
Kierland mackerland maker Lane hi
Caroline subject is my life a lie hi
Justin whoa
that's intense hi Justin and Christian
my name is Carrie and Carolyn hi Carolyn
[ __ ] can you guess how it's pronounced
okay if we obviously can't
um doubt it she says yep you're right I
recently started recently that'd be
tough to have a name she must know that
people have a hard time with it uh and
you have a hard time in general isn't it
yes and I really want to know them it I
I've been it's been interesting getting
to know I'm getting to know this new
crew that I'm working with and there's
some fun names but I I'm I'm trying to
learn them them all uh I think it it
really helps getting to know a person
where did the name come from you know
um doubt uh is that just an obvious uh
yeah
okay back to Carrie I recently started
listening and noticed you both talk
about pronunciations of names names a
lot oh boy anywho
I visited Ireland recently for the first
time and asked some Irishmen how they
would pronounce it
my dad oh so
so is it not even clear in her family
my dad always said it's oh like you said
mackerland macarland macarlean
people even call him Mac because of this
but in Ireland they say it's macaron add
a little Irish twang would you my Carlin
so which do I go by is my life a lie
love the podcast love the diverse guests
you guys interview talk about and love
the lightning round as well I've always
loved your movies Justin just as Emma
Stone and Zombieland says about Bill
Murray quote you have a direct line to
My Funny Bone oh I like that line and
it's very sweet here
um Christian you're just as funny
wow very nice don't sell yourself short
why don't people keep thinking I'm
selling myself short no
you hadn't sold yourself
um plus you share the same name as my
boyfriend so she didn't write it like
that I happen to say it like that
boyfriend oh carrot
um so you get some points there okay you
get some points from Karen I'll take him
where I can get him
um would you rather would you rather
know what everyone around you is
thinking about this I've thought about
this
would you rather know what everyone
around you is thinking about you or be
completely oblivious to the people
around you
love the Pod that is a really good
question it's completely oblivious that
people are like to what extent uh I
guess you're just unaware of like your
presence
that would be I I would have to I would
have to do the first one if that's okay
because then you'd never be able to
interact with anything exactly but if if
it if she means it more like this maybe
like
you're oblivious to what they think of
you
or you know what they think of you
well she says would you know what
everyone around you is thinking about
you or be completely oblivious to the
people see I think the second one is
meant to be the opposite of the first
one so if the first one is you know what
everyone thinks about that would just be
normal it would just be like you are in
everyday life not normal It's like
because Normal is something in between I
think because I guess because you have a
sense of what people think of you or
um sometimes it's obvious sometimes they
tell you what they think of you but
imagine if you had no clue what they
were thinking of you I I have a real
fear of losing that sense you know yeah
it's scary that's a tough one if it is
that if those are the two options I
might need to know what everyone thinks
about me and then just deal with that
and then maybe I'd be an incredible
maybe adjust my behavior accordingly
yeah you're right you would it would be
hard I mean it would be such a blow to
your ego and you'd have to get used to
it but I think
I think it might be best in the long run
I know what people think yeah I think it
might be helpful actually to go to Just
Just For Your Existence I I think for
your social existence I think I would
start hearing this a lot like oh he's
talking a lot or like you know that like
nerd you know well then you adjust then
yeah then you that's true start talking
less anywho uh back to Carrie love the
Pod Curry Mac that's how she she calls
me Cody Mac
um thank you Curry mccurlin or macarleen
um what a nice letter and thank you for
your letter uh this was a great question
too and if you guys would like to write
in we love getting these letters and
reading them and our email address is
life is short wondery.com
and thank you to Questlove or as Justin
calls him Amir yes Amir just the coolest
and funniest I mean what a great guy
yeah it was a good one I just wanna
talking to him made me want to I mean I
felt like we were hanging out I mean we
were hanging out but I want I just
wanted more he's just an easy
fascinating guy to be around he made me
want to buy some records yeah right oh
my God oh God bought his record I know
200 000. what an interesting human being
um I'm so glad we we got to do that I've
always been I've always really liked
being around Quest but I've never had
time Amir why am I downgrading it's a
cool name to say Quest yeah I'm here is
two but quest to school yeah Quest
um
okay anyway thank you guys uh for
listening and we will talk to you soon
bye
life is short is hosted by me Justin
long and his co-hosted by you Christian
law also produced by him and it's
produced by Megan Monaco and Katie Allen
and Senior producers Michelle Lanz audio
engineer Sergio Enriquez executive
producer Marsha Louis all for a company
called wondering bye everyone
dude
[Music]
what it says about him is that he he's
more concerned with how he looks how
cool he looks or like sophisticated or
whatever it is try to imagine who you
would give your first impression Rose if
you had one for these guys that's tough
yeah but all right but keep in mind um
okay wait but I think it's already
happened I I that guy who don't tell me
you know yeah I don't remember his name
he was just like one of the normal ones
how do you know who got the first
impression uh
know who I would give it to so far oh
it's already happened for you yeah I
have a front runner oh that's fine but I
don't remember his name he was just one
of those guys
all right we'll see him again wait till
the end of the regulator okay okay
all right
hi Hannah hi I'm Ryan like why did he
have to come on what if the skating is
usually different
remember I'm the guy who skated him if
they gave that or they're
I think they tell them you know make
yourself known like make it a member or
they just see the show and they know how
it works they know that like it's easier
to talk about to be remembered for a
certain thing like um this skateboard
guy I'm the Box guy I'm the guy who came
[ __ ]
helicoptered in um
hey Prime members you can listen to Life
Is Short ad free on Amazon music
download the Amazon music app today